una valla que desemboca en el mar y que
separa irremediablemente el norte global
del sur global es la frontera entre
ceuta el enclave español en el norte de
áfrica y marruecos 11 kilómetros
vigilados por las fuerzas de seguridad
españolas y marroquíes su objetivo
impedir la migración irregular desde el
continente africano hacia territorio
español
son casi tres décadas de colaboración
entre españa y marruecos una
colaboración que consiste en
externalizar las políticas migratorias
hacia marruecos para contener la llegada
de emigrantes a cambio de altas sumas de
dinero el primer acuerdo entre los dos
países fue en 1992 un año después se
instalaron las vallas que separan ceuta
de marruecos y en 2002 terminó de
instalarse un sistema de alta tecnología
para controlar la frontera
desde entonces las bayas no han dejado
de crecer esta misma semana el gobierno
español aprobó una partida de 30
millones de euros para este tipo de
cooperación con marruecos
uno de los puntos más polémicos de los
acuerdos son las llamadas devoluciones
en caliente el retorno de emigrantes
inmediatamente después de cruzar
irregularmente la frontera algunos
sistemas de justicia internacionales lo
consideran una práctica ilegal al no
esperar a determinar si los migrantes
tienen derecho a asilo o no antes de
volver a expulsarlos pero que en españa
se permite por los acuerdos bilaterales
con marruecos
que estas devoluciones sólo se
consideran legales si los migrantes son
mayores de edad y se detectan en su
intento de cruzar la frontera
unas premisas que organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian que no se han
cumplido con la reciente entrada masiva
de migrantes entre los que se cuentan
1.500 menores de edad de los cuales
muchos según estas denuncias habrían
sido devueltos en caliente a marruecos